number one he went according to this
manifesto attributed to him
he went to seek blessings with this
group called the templar knights which
they are trying to revive some say
that they're like a secret society out
there and
andrew brevlick who also was a he was a
christian
and he went again not representing
christianity true christianity or the
true jesus of
jesus we make that clear he went and
sought his blessings he's supposed to be
this night this templar night also
so he was going to seek blessings from
this group the templar knights that's
still
allegedly out there why is he doing that
imagine real quickly
what would happen if someone went to
seek blessings from al-qaeda or desh
or this isis what would happen why are
you seeking blessings from them for what
so are you non-muslim or you're or
you're muslim if you're doing that
so you're going to seek blessings from
the templar knights are you a christian
you're not a christian why are you
seeking their blessings
think about that i'll let you decide at
the end let's move let's move on
number two the dates on his gun there
were specific dates you had also
some extreme elements who considered who
called themselves christian they did
some terrorist acts
and he had those dates of those attacks
on there and
dates to crusader events now you know
the crusaders
they wrecked havoc in the land you know
the the pope who let them out
these people absolved them of their sins
gave a free pass
pretty much told them if they go out and
they let criminals out
rapists out to go out and that's what
they did they wrecked havoc and they
terrorized
so they're trying to re bring
this crusade so he has those crusader
dates
on his weapon now you tell me why are
they there
he's christian not christian what's
specifically his agenda
it's up to you to decide at the end i'm
just bringing these important points to
you he also had a crusader song from the
techniques now the techniques
are this extreme element of from a
nationality called the serbs
now we don't try to put down serbs or
croatians or anybody because
that's a nationality and in every
nationality you have extreme elements so
we don't
just like bash the whole ethnic group
the ethnicity but you had chetniks these
were people who were out there
they committed one of the not the
greatest genocide genocide after world
war
ii and this song was made for karadzic
these people like kharajis majes
specifically hear this war criminal
he was convicted of war crimes they had
rape camps death camps they killed
innocent men women and children
this was also under it was hidden nobody
called them
christian terrorists but they were
hiding behind christianity you had
priests blessing their guns and weapons
and this song
was a motivating song for this crusader
these techniques who were hiding behind
christianity i don't call them true
christians
and they went and committed these these
atrocities
this terrorism the greek orthodox church
described him as quote
one of the most prominent sons of our
lord jesus christ working for peace
now he thanked god on many occasions so
what is he is he
he's he's he's thanking god so what
religion is is he on
said thank god goodbye god bless you all
now imagine if a muslim
he said alhamdulillah what would they do
with that what would the media the
islamophobes
what would they do with that again what
would i'm leaving that up to you what
has been done
already again islam is vilified
put on the stand and the list goes on of
all the evil
evil malicious things that are done he
used crusader
terrorist crusader lingo
such as calling the muslims saracens
he also encouraged in one part he said
he said death is certain you may die in
the service
to some grand crusade or pass away in a
hospice
so look again what would happen if
someone was
invited you might you can die in the
grand service of a grand
and they use they throw jihad out there
they say in a grand jihad or in a
hospice
so he would be calling to a jihad right
and jihadist simply means to struggle
and to strive
against evil against oppression against
yourself your desires and the list goes
on we're not covering that here
but then what if this was used
and now this word was thrown in the
opposite thing happened
the same way here he's inviting to a
grand crusade
using lingo and calling muslims with
crusader terms
could they take this and manipulate it
and say he was a christian and this is
radical christianity like they do with
islam
clear double standards and hypocrisy
is what we're pointing out he has a
whole page
dedicated where it says two christians
now i believe
i first thought these were his words but
i think because they're in quotations
he's quoting someone and it says the
people worthy of glory the people
blessed by god
and this is by a another
crusader pope a terrorist who went
terrorizing people
he's trying to invoke a crusade so
imagine someone trying to invoke
what they islamophobes call like these
jihadis they're coming to get us
and all the other things that they
perpetuate to make you scared of muslims
to create this manufactured hate and
fear when statistically
it is factual the data shows
that muslims commit the least acts of
terrorism
this is statistical and factual you can
check it up
and now the final point he's he's
because he's doing a question and answer
back and forth and he asked him so are
you christian
it's a simple and it's a simple quote
are you a christian someone says are you
muslim
if you're not muslim i'm not muslim but
then how does he respond he says
uh that that's complicated i'll let you
know when i figure it out now imagine on
the other side
if that was and all of these i want you
to go and compare
if this was a muslim and same thing back
and forth what kind of
games they would be you know analyzing
it all of these points they would be
analyzing and they'd have talk shows and
back and forth and crossfires on this
and it would be 24 7
media and they would be trying to
perpetuate this and
and fueling more the hate in the
division so he mentions giving people
the kind of honesty that this generation
they want and thirst for
so you should be honest when it comes to
talking about muslims and islam honest
academic not making up these lies like
we called you out for last time
now that was in the past you can make it
right for that and for the future
we you can go back and how we address
that and you can go ahead
and instead of the copy and paste out of
context what you are doing
you can call an academic a scholar of
islam
someone who's in this area of expertise
and come and let's talk
and let's work together or would you
continue
to espouse hate misinformation and lies
about islam and muslims you showed like
you had some empathy
for those 49 innocent human beings that
had died in a house of worship a house
of god
and you were you were coming off like
you're genuine and sincere and only god
knows what's in your heart
and my heart just breaks for the
families the people affected
in christ church new zealand in this
just
deplorable terrorist mass murder attack
sending prayers you said and it breaks
your heart as you said but
i'm asking you but then the next day you
go and bring on one of the biggest
number one
islamophobes in the world whose only
mission
is fueling people like this terrorists
who did that
people who listen to people like that
they can only develop
hate if someone comes out and all you
can
learn from this is to hate islam and
muslims
what good are they contributing to
making peace and understanding
and giving proper education when they're
you're giving them a platform to promote
lies misunderstanding and hate
and that's what you did and that's
ingenuous and insincere
so you went from being sincere and then
you went what seemed to be sincere
saying your heart was broke and you're
making these these
saying these beautiful nice things and
then where did you go on from there
you bring on the biggest islamophobe one
of the top islamophobes
haters out there so wrapping it up
one final thing you had mentioned we
should not be
a people dividing the country for clicks
dividing the country
for clicks
why don't we stick with that if you
truly want
peace and understanding work towards it
the muslims are there
so you can espouse these bigoted
hateful this hate rhetoric towards
muslim towards islam and muslims
these lies that you perpetuate these
insults
towards prophet muhammad peace and
blessings be upon them
or you can go ahead and try to work
towards a common good like you were
saying
and i address my christian
colleagues friends i have a lot of them
christian friends out there
to call out people like this these are
not the best of you
these are not the best of you who are
hating to compound the problem
call them out be if they be in your
churches i've shown you guys what
happens when someone
goes and even makes a joke about being
a part of this group isis i've showed
you what happens there
yes
yes
but what about these people who are
trying to bring these ideas
who are trying to incite this hate in
the churches the politicians
you need to call them out you cannot let
this hate rhetoric that leads
islamophobia kills
it leads to what happened of tragedy
of evil in new zealand it leads to that
don't let it come to that
jews and christians muslims
we are all here on this earth nobody's
going anywhere
so we need to work together in peace and
harmony but the constant islamophobia
the manufactured hate fear the quarter
of a million that's spent
traumatizing people that's what you're
doing perpetuating lies
misinformation give the muslims a shot
to get out there represent themselves
go ahead and ask them the tough
questions and let the people decide
let the people decide and i'm letting
you decide now at the end
could they because that's what we
started with i asked you i'm gonna i'm
gonna bring up some
some points from the manifesto
attributed to this terrorist
that killed 49 innocent human beings
muslims
in a house of worship a house of god
could the media as they do always with
islam and muslims
could they from what i just mentioned
can they associate and say no no he was
a christian
practicing christianity and then called
christianity radical christianity
a christian terrorist which nobody's
doing and i'm not saying that they
should
but they should be fair and balanced
because you cannot
based on one individual or a group of
individuals
malign a whole faith a whole way of life
like islam or christianity let's keep it
fair and balance pointing out the
double standards and hypocrisy here on
the daily show
our door is always open to mr crowd and
others with an invitation of peace
because we're people of peace and we end
with the greeting of jesus shalom lake
peace
peace be with you